Madison says that these arrangements
here this connection between the people
and the government it gives power to the
government locates ultimate authority in
the people prescribes how the people
must must hold opinions over time to
make them effective this is a set of
arrangements what does this make it
possible for them to do they can
delegate the authority to more than one
place you can give the legislative power
to the Congress in article 1 of the
Constitution you can give the executive
power to the president in article 2 of
the Constitution they each have their
own relationship with the sovereign
people they are quite equal as regards
Authority you can give all the judicial
power in article 3 to the courts and you
can use article 1 and article 2
institutions to combine to appoint the
judges
you can leave most of the power in the
hands of the state and you can protect
that in article 4 of the Constitution
you see the symmetry and the strength of
that all made possible by this consent
and representation is the sovereign was
in the government whatever part of the
government in Madison rights is over and
over in the Federalist Hamilton to
whatever part of the government the
sovereign was in that would become the
dominant part whereas now we can
separate the powers and then they can be
stronger which you need but still also
safe